I read an interview with some director
who said you really don't know how to
direct a movie until you've directed at
least four or five movies you agree with
that way I feel like yeah I mean I don't
know I'm well
I feel like you can you can with each
one you learn enough that you can get
through the next thing and you can make
it better and you learn stuff but I
don't know if you've probably even after
five movies if you feel like oh I got
this right it's like it's like with
anything the more you learn the more it
sounds so cliche but the more you learn
the more you feel like oh God the more
there is to do but yeah I've got to jump
into something and delve into it
completely I can't just be into one
thing and then another thing and then
another thing you gotta really sort of
immerse yourself in it right well you
started directing stuff when you were
doing Rock videos right well that's why
I started with videos and now when what
I've been doing in between movies is
doing some TV and some TV commercials
yeah what did you what was that
commercial you did for like wool
lighters
seems odd no you know what I've always
Rob Zombie I've always heard that
commercial directing is probably the
best training for movie directing that
these are the guys these are guys who
actually are on The Cutting Edge of the
technology because commercials they put
up a lot of money for them and you can
and you can experiment right well what's
good about what what I like about
commercials is um
it feels like you know it'd be like if
you had you did a tour and you played
one show a year and after that show
you'd be like that that was a terrible
show you know we you need to do in a lot
of shows you kind of get in the groove
and at least the commercials you feel
like you keep your sort of directing
chops up because you're there and you're
working because sometimes if you haven't
done a movie for two years you walk on
set and you feel like this is awkward
where is a swollen commercial well I
mean did you do some sort of weird
commercial or was it pretty weird it was
this I mean the thing with the
commercials they're not my ideas they
come to the Ad Agency has agonized over
it for sometimes a year wow and they
bring in the boards what I liked about
you know they wanted to do something of
course that was like scary right it's a
pretty weird word like commercial it
looks like a guy's dragging a dead body
through a field from Woolite for walleye
wow it was this an internet commercial
engineering no no it's still on T it was
so successful then they're still running
it they've been running for two years
I've seen it so much on television do
you get paid every time they run it is
it one of those no you don't you get
paid one shot deal yeah oh what a shame
what looks like a body bag through a
field in like this creepy field there's
a spooky house and stuff it looks like a
serial killer and then he starts pulling
out laundry and torturing the laundry on
these torture devices and it's like
don't torture your clothes use Woolite
but at the end of the commercial there's
all the nice stuff like the pretty
people wearing their nice clothes yeah
that was the stuff that was fun to film
because it was so easy